I love metrics. Yes, so we can build something and we're not using them today. It drives me insane
Yeah, yeah, again that would be like things, but we can definitely
Bullying towards it. Yeah, because I got my budgets, but I want to be able to say what's my actual versus
actual versus estimate. I want to be able to be looking at that and I'm not
Because you have everything
We don't we're not doing it. I know we're not doing it right which is why we started talking
Yeah
So the bet is fine. Now we get into the project phase. Yeah, it's a bit gets approved
You you would say that bet is approved for job or fun work that to a job
So that's most to job
Now once we get to the job that is where we have to assign the phases. Yes, right and it gets auto assigned
The
Ruff up and then trim and start up and one and be right every job will have these four phases
Yeah, it default now what information do you think we would want to capture an addition to what we already have there
So schedule is one part of it. So I should be for each phases. I should be able to create a new work
Order. Yes, right and as part of the work order
I should be able to say who is the engineer that I'm assigning it to correct and then install it and then start time and time
Of when it should be scheduled. Yep, and then
Notes and
Images of correct. So those are the that's the things. Okay. That's it right. Yeah, yeah, okay, and then
To that then you have invoice pending paid. Yes, which gets since so you say a work order
It's complete and when you say complete it triggers the invoice process correct and says you're now ready to send it in voice
Correct, and you'll for now you'll tackle that. We'll figure out the I'm doing it manually, right?
And so this is a set this is a sad reality. This is another thing. I'm not missing anything. At least I hope not
So this is what we did, right? So I'm always on hand to make sure this is updated and the reason why is because that's how I've built right
And so if we click on whatever click on one of these right here. Here's one one example right so this is a job
It's been assigned material. It's not up. It's not up there, but we've completed the material or the equipment is on site
And I have a building that right so we have ready not ready complete right there
Right, so it's not it's not so I taught it track it every single job
So I just go through here like for example, and I'll say okay
Build serves complete build. Yeah, that one's complete and this this is how I I tell myself that yes
You've already built it. Yes, you've already attached it right and so like here
I know I haven't done anything what I've no I need to look at these because I haven't done anything with them
Yeah, so I've only built this one for the week and I know I got to do that something because I haven't done jack shit
Yeah, and so this is a work this right here is a work order, right?
So this one got on here installed return grill, but we got like no detail on it now
We know today that it's a 16 by 25 grill or whatever it is
It's we got to go back and install it. We know today, but a year from now
Shit, we don't know what that is going on and this is what this is where we're missing the data
That's why the centralized spot needs to happen yeah and eventually and not now
But eventually I'd like to say we can pick a drop down and we say we need this this is this and that automatically sign it to the work order
Material list. Yes, and then I'll have a pole in the screech
We can take a screenshot like yes, this one right and I would need a screenshot of this
Which which one you are?
So this feels now let me ask for every work are every phase do you have this like you need to finish the material
Yep, make it on order equipment order
So these it so the material needs to be ordered so that needs to be a task that needs to be assigned to someone
Order the material order the equipment order the queen city pre-fab
We need to be able to have a sign there so they can click it off that needs to be a phase
That needs to be a task within the face. So you're not just assigning the leads
You're also assigning
Some of the tasks there's some other task that are involved with each part of that to so now this if the these things is a the phase load of the work on the level
We could be either it could be it could be so it could be at the work let's make it into work order level
Because you're creating a work order or we're creating a work order for
The first work order is the job, right and so we can assign it certain parts of it. Yeah, yeah, and
And okay, so then we work we have to do then is each work order will have sub tasks. Yes, right so that you can say
You know what the first one is spending and who is the installer or who is the person who needs to take care of it right
So that when you assign them it shows up into their tasks, right and it's now their responsibility to mark that
That's complete once that is done. It's a good answer and next one to answer once they mark that is complete
Then that gets green here and the next one gets enabled and it tells like when you come there
You should be able to see the pending jobs and see which ones are waiting on what so you can base maybe follow up
Is it always Syria or parallel task also happened?
No, I think this is these are all this all you say this is per phase or is it per work order?
What we do this per work order because it might be a change order
Then needs to be assigned to somebody take a look at this hey order of this material
Hey, go do this right it might because there might be something because a lot of times
You know, we're talking about something this got moved in here, but what happens is that you know what I'm gonna finish the whole second floor
We weren't gonna do it, right? So now we are it's $12,000 right?
So now there's multiple things involved rather than the $20 girl that need to be changed
Right, so there's multiple things, but it could be the same format
Right, so it could be a task and that could be it could be real simple like that right okay
Yeah, so it could be different tasks and this task is it going to be fixed
For every job and work every phase every job every work. It'll be the same every time same. So by default
We can just set that up yes and keep it open for you
You are someone to assign guests installers and assign the task for someone and we say you we need
Okay
Okay, so we have to then work with Brian on that
Are you good with everything yeah, so far from your jump in when there's yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm collecting as much as details
So that we get heavily into it so I'm pretty sure we build some initial thing and then we come back and kind of
We get together
Yeah, because I'm also trying to see how much you know we need to be able to build yeah
On this okay, so this tasks I will be there and then I know we go from one to the other which is the same thing
Yeah, I'll take such and whatever you want
Okay, and is that anything else you manage here apart from I see that you you have a family
You go through this right and right now
I don't know if you can get calendar also in but we can add that
Okay, yeah, well you have a calendar to be able to see who is working on what who is assigned to what yeah
And then that will then bring up the next thing that we're saying like okay
I have a job that I need to get done you know, let me see an open slot and could see who is open at that right when in time
That's so you know, this is this week, right, so then here's next week
So we got stuff already on for next week week after we got all of his files
Right, yeah, you guys you know people don't think at that part of it. It's always week the week right
So that's next week right there that'll get all changed around stuff like that because there's stuff that's on for this week that it get done
Yeah, yeah, he did go do that by the way
Yeah, yeah, no, he called me good
He's not going to set the year down. He's going to let's do money
Okay
So I have enough information for us to start measuring the things and you take that old towel by the way
Oh, okay, yeah, thanks. I wrote all over but you it helped. Yes, it'll help when you listen to your yes
I'll listen to that and then kind of build it because I want to initially
I would try to focus on
Like a mass of sheep which will have the bit information the dog and financial work on it and I'll take your sheep and just modify it
So the bitboard looks like this. Okay, so you know these are all all that if you want to picture of this
Yes, we have
No, I don't think you
I can send this to you. Yeah, if you can send me the
So the bitboard and then what what is the job?
It's on tracking area. You're all the jobs
Okay, he's rolled right here. Yeah, I love
So I'll split it up and map it